I'm delighted that I'm here today with
phil knight the founder and chairman of
nike and of course for whom our new
academic home will be named it's going
to be a fantastic new campus with eight
buildings and three adjoining
quadrangles phil was a 1962 graduate of
our MBA program he's here at the
Business School again
welcome back Phil Knight it's wonderful
to be here thank you now a lot has
happened since 1962
Phil you sure as built and and lead Nike
it's an amazing worldwide global company
19 billion in sales the leader in sports
and fitness as you look back on that and
your entrepreneurship your innovation
your global leadership and management
what role did the Stanford MBA program
play if at all in all of this I know I
mean I think it's it's almost certainly
true that if there was no extension
Graduate School of Business of be no
Nike that it was in the Entrepreneurship
class that Frank Shallenberger taught
that I wrote the paper which really was
the equivalent today's business plan
that really became the blueprint for
Nike and it was out of that that I
really had the courage and the
enthusiasm to start this company that
ultimately became Nike you mentioned
Frank Shallenberger was the faculty
member I remember Frank very well how
was how was he in leading that class
what's your recollection of Frank as a
faculty member well in a single word he
was inspirational that he was really
motivating and he really got my own
enthusiasm going
and and one of the things I liked about
him that he would frequently you know
give the class motto which is the only
time you must not the only time you must
not fail is the last time you try and it
was to have the courage to try and that
if you failed it wasn't necessarily you
know something that was a black mark on
you forever you could go out and try
again and all of those things came
together his inspiration is obviously
his own experiences with starting small
companies and the enthusiasm of the
class in general they all contributed
mightily to my really having the
confidence and enthusiasm to start this
whole thing now when you left Stanford
you didn't just immediately start a
company full time you took awhile to get
yourself there
as I recall yeah I mean first of all
that I had or during the course of class
I'd written several Japanese shoe
manufacturers about the possibility of
importing shoes I didn't get a single
reply but I did on graduation to go over
there and made a contact with the shoe
manufacturer and it took a company
limited and but it wasn't a direct leap
to success that it took 18 months to get
samples and another six months to get an
order in so a slow getting started in
the meantime I had to go to work and I
can remember I had just gotten married
and I said to my wife I was in my second
year of teaching at Portland State and I
said you know for we cracked $300,000 in
sales this year I'm gonna go full-time
and we hit $2.99 said close enough and
what year was that that would have been
1969 right so seven years after you left
here you know I think sometimes students
feel gee I can write a business plan to
start a company well it happens a lot
faster these days I think but I know
that that the first year sales first
year of sales were 1964 and we sold
$8,000 and we made a $240 profit so we
managed expenses pretty well pretty
fantastic no cash burn right away no
that's right now I remember very well at
night
ninety-two when the school honored you
with the Arbuckle award which is the
highest honor we can bestow upon an alum
or a friend of the school at the time I
was an alum and I was in the audience
when you talked in one thing that came
back to me about that talk you made a
very interesting observation that that
by that even sometimes people said you
will why do you work you don't need to
work you were doing very well with Nike
and and you made the observation gee
nobody asked John Updike why does he
write and nobody asked James DePriest
why do you conduct and do you see
artistic dimensions or analogies to
being a business leader Oh totally that
and I think it's one of the areas that I
would I would say that society
misunderstands that I think management
is is really an art I mean obviously
there's certain scientific principles
and there's certain arithmetic formulas
you can bring to it at the end of the
day managing people is an art and I
think it's as demanding and and as
artistic as writing and painting and the
other other arts if you will and so I
think that there really is kind of a
misunderstanding on how hard the art of
management is and the fact that it
really is an art and I think I look on
my own people that I've looked up to
like Warren Buffett or Akio Morita the
founder of Sony they obviously stayed at
their companies long past any financial
need for really for the contribution
they were making to their company and to
really to the world in general if you
think about this campus which is such a
wonderful transformative event for the
Stanford Business School it really marks
us in a new dimension of our leadership
in management education our role at
Stanford University
well what motivated you to to want to
help us with this campus well I think
first of all the campus the new campus
is going to be sensational I mean I just
really kind of appreciated the scope of
the whole
saying today as I watch them tear down
their old buildings and start to begin
to dig holes and I think it's really a
tribute to you as Dean and the deans
that have preceded you I can't think
that Stanford has never had anything but
a great game in their business school
and this is really just a culmination of
really the greatness and I think that
you know I was happy to be able to be
involved obviously Stanford meant a lot
to me and and it's really my hope that
out there are a student or lots of
students have come out come down to come
to Stanford and and have it as
transformative for them as it was for me
you know one other thing we always ask
our students when they apply here we
want to know more about them you know
about what kind of people they are their
character what matters to them as you
think about your business life your
personal life what how for our students
would you define a life well-lived well
I think almost the most important thing
is is is do something you enjoy
that's what's fulfilling it but that was
one of Frank Shallenberger its biggest
you know lessons that if you're gonna if
you're gonna start a small business or
involved a small business they're going
to be many many dark hours and if you
don't really enjoy what you're doing
this is it has no chance and I think is
again if somebody else said that you
know a great football coach you know you
can't tell the difference between his
hobby and his business well Phil Knight
we welcome you back we're very excited
about today
the groundbreaking of the knight
Management Center the home of the
Stanford Business School it's an
enormous pleasure for me today to be
here today and really quite emotional
that that the school obviously has meant
so much in my life and to be able to
give back a little bit makes me feel
really great mm-hmm well it makes
thousands of others feel really great
too and we thank you